and finally new rule in today's merger
crazy economy everybody needs a partner
that's how we got the likes of Exxon
Mobil GlaxoSmithKline JPMorgan Chase and
it's why I now work for the phone
company that's right Time Warner itself
a giant merger which owns HBO got bought
by AT&T have I noticed a difference not
so far no interference but also no hi
how you doing I mean they could have
called
they are the phone company but I get it
we live in the age of get bigger or get
eaten
in fact I look forward to the brave new
day when there will be only two
companies apples on and Goldman Google
Mart
[Applause]
[Music]
at Goldman Google Mart I only have to
imagine the words I think I need more
dog food
seconds later a robot drone shoves it in
my pants the Republican Party certainly
understands the concept of merging to
survive in recent years they were facing
a serious demographic problem America
was becoming younger and browner and
they were becoming whiter and dinner
they had lost the popular vote in six of
the last seven presidential elections
and realized they couldn't win by
themselves so they did what any smart
corporation would do they merged with a
giant oil company
that's right the Republican Party and
Russia have merged their the Trump
Russia group two great corporations now
operating out of the same evil lair oh
sure Republicans used to hate Russia as
much as they hated taxes and welfare and
sexually active women but fiddle-faddle
40 percent of Republicans now say they
either approve of Russian interference
in our elections or don't object
strongly they're even wearing I'd rather
be a Russian than a Democrat t-shirts
say it's funny cuz we're traitors I
guess the news saying is better red than
well red
[Music]
and this fall the Trump Russia group has
a strategy to win the next election
using cheating hacking rigging rat
[ __ ] vote voter rolls tampering and
disinformation campaigns so my message
Democrats is get with the times
there are to borrow a phrase new rules
and since we now accept that it's OK to
merge your party with a foreign power
I'd like to be the first member of the
resistance to say China if you're
listening
I hope you can find Donald Trump's tax
returns
if they get to bring in Russia as their
ringer we get to bring an our own
country and I pick China dnc meat msg
walk the boat baby
[Applause]
when they go low we go low main who
better to hack voting machines in the
country whose children assembled them if
you're gonna turn over your party to a
foreign power
at least pick the right one Russia and
you kidding it's like the Republicans
looked over all the companies that could
merge with and pick Sears China is the
future
Russia is a mobbed-up has been petro
state run by men and purple satin shirts
their main exports are blood doping and
car crash videos the male life
expectancy in Russia is lower than North
Korea their GDP is smaller than Italy's
it's like merging with a Halloween store
China is building giant ports and
highways all over the world they're
going to overtake America as the world's
largest economy in a year now and unlike
us they can actually build a wall
in Hong Kong they put on a light show
every night for free and China has a
mole so big it has an indoor beach ready
to merge now I thought so
and president gee very strong leader
very strong unlike what we got in this
country wouldn't it be better if we got
along with China that would be a good
thing not a bad thing a good thing not a
bad
[Music]